Thank you to Skillshare for supporting
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
If you are one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the description
you can get a free trial of
Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
There’s a lot of green in the world,
and that is thanks in no small part
to the microcosmos. Not only did cyanobacteria
lay the foundation for an oxygenated Earth,
they laid the foundation for chloroplasts when
they were endosymbiotically consumed helping
their host take on their photosynthetic machinery.
For most of us, the green we are confronted with
every day is a more macroscopic kind, the leaves
you see on trees and grass. And if you’re on a
hike, you might notice some squishy bundles of
green flush against a tree, or low to the ground.
“Oh, a moss,” you might tell yourself. Or “oh, a
lichen!” And then, perhaps, you move on, unsure
of whether you’ve called it the right thing but
distracted by the many other sights around you.
But today we’re not going to let
that happen. We’re going to linger
on our non-vascular plant friends
and look at them a little closer,
learning more about what they are, and why
only one of those things is actually a plant.
…it’s the moss. Moss is the plant.
More specifically, moss is a member of the
plant division called Bryophyta. And when we say
that moss is a non-vascular plant, what we mean
is that it doesn’t have the vascular tissue like a
xylem and phloem to transport water and nutrients
around the plant. This lack of vasculature keeps
mosses short so that they can still transport
nutrients and water easily. And while they don’t
technically have roots or leaves as defined for
vascular plants, you’ll see the equivalent
structures like their root-like filaments
called rhizoids and also these leafy parts.
And mosses provide a lot of benefits to the
environment around them. They help prevent
erosion, and they can provide insulation.
And we’ve seen ourselves how mosses provide a
home to some of our favorite microbial companions.
Lichen on the other hand though they are
sometimes called non-vascular plants,
they are very definitely not
plants. So what is lichen?
In a 2010 Discovery article, the lichenologist
Trevor Goward described lichen as “fungi
that have discovered agriculture.”
To be more specific,
lichen is a symbiotic union between a fungus and
an algae. The fungus provides access to nutrients,
as well as protection from the elements
and UV light. And in exchange, the algae
provides its own photosynthetic capabilities.
Now that sounds straightforward enough, especially
when you consider all the symbiotic relationships
we’ve learned about in the microcosmos.
Put together the right fungus, and the
right algae, and you get a lichen…right?
Well, scientists have attempted to
create lichens in the lab by culturing
the appropriate partners together, but
with little success. And it turns out
that that might be because we’ve underestimated
the number of partners involved. In one study,
scientists found that there was at least
one other fungal partner in their lichens.
And it could be that other species have many
many other members involved, making them
far more complex than we have understood thus far.
For something so strange and complicated,
lichens are amazingly prevalent: they’re estimated
to cover up to around 6% of our planet’s surface,
whether that’s on the side of a tree or on a rock
or even on dunes. And lichens have this ability
to not only latch on to all sorts of surfaces,
but to disrupt them and convert them into a more
habitable environment by releasing minerals and
creating the early ingredients for future soil.
And so because lichens are so important to
cultivating the seemingly inhospitable parts of
our world, many have thought lichens were possibly
one of the first organisms to make it onto land.
But research from 2019 has suggested that lichens
didn’t find their way to land until well after
vascular plants did. In fact, it could be as long
as 100 million years after, raising new questions
about how plants and our own earth evolved.
Now mosses are also part of this story,
as they were likely among the earliest plants to
make it onto land. And their ancient spread may
have played an important role in raising
oxygen levels to where they are today,
allowing for the evolution of not just other plant
life, but of more complex animal bodies as well.
With that said, the trick with evolution
is to know that creating a whole world
is much more complicated than any one
step would have you believe. Mosses and
lichens carry their own worlds in their spreading
masses, not fully invisible like the microcosmos,
but often underfoot and easy to ignore. But
maybe if you spot some on a walk, take a moment
to look a little closer, and to wonder what
other secrets they might possibly hide.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Skillshare
for supporting this video.
After staring at all of this moss,
maybe you’re thinking, “You know,
I could use more plants around the house.” But
you might also be worried that you don’t have the
green thumb necessary to keep those plants alive.
Well, with classes like Happy Houseplants,
hosted by the botanist Chris Satch, Skillshare
can make sure you have everything you need
to pot and care for your plants so that they live
long, healthy lives. That’s right. Skillshare,
you can learn Python, you can learn
plants. This course can teach you
how to troubleshoot for your plants as well as
more specific skills like how to pot a cactus.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth. It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you, and
they’re always launching new premium classes,
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
A Premium Membership will give you
unlimited access, so you can join the
classes and communities that are right for you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month, and if you’re one
of the first 1,000 people to click the
link in the description, you can get a free
trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Everybody whose names are on the screen
right now? They are our Patreon patrons.
If you like what we do here and you’d like to
join them check out patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss,
check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there’s always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.